three
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
the mjolnir exosuit is now complete
[Music]
even though this technology will save
humanity in the war to come
i must remind myself
liquid crystal cannot rise on its own
[Music]
titanium alloy cannot prevail in the
face of extinction
armor cannot hope
it all means nothing
[Music]
until you step inside
[Music]
ah
am i dead already i must be i mean this
is a punishment right
this isn't happening i'm going to have
to make an emergency landing
hold on
no yes no you
i can't stand it you are
breathe no you don't get to tell me what
to do
you don't get to tell me anything we're
are you even listening i count three
anti-aircraft cannons
three what you'll be safe here oh
i'll be safe safe
i haven't been safe since i found you i
found you remember
you were out there on your own and you'd
still be out if it wasn't for me
i thought i was going home there won't
be a home if we don't stop the banished
you keep saying that we're outgoing
outnumbered
i know i saw condors over there i'm
going to dig through them and find one
with the working sleep space drive
and when you're done with this war we'll
get away from here
far away wait here
oh please
let me see what i can find cannons first
when i get back we can look
together
[Music]
okay be good
uh
[Music]
[Music]
uh
oh
[Music]
[Music]
me
foreign
[Music]
ugh
uh
uh
[Music]
the uh lost this
war months ago your people
are broken scattered
hunted defeated
by me i wish i could tell you it was
difficult
but it wasn't
we are one step ahead always
the ring is already under our control
soon the auditorium is well
the hard and the banished share the same
we fight together to honor the will
of atriox
lost alone
but hear
you now stand
this is my last
fight true test
of legends our story
will outlive us both
[Music]
set a fire in your heart spartan
bear your fangs
fight hard my world
we hope you enjoyed your first look at
halo infinite's campaign
i'm incredibly proud of the team at 343
and we're thrilled to share a hint
of the epic battles that await you on
the next chapter of master chief's
journey
this is the most ambitious campaign
we've ever created at 343
for the first time players will have the
freedom to explore a mysterious new halo
ring
that's several times larger than our
last two halo games combined
hill infinite has been built from the
ground up to take full advantage of xbox
series x
bigger battles epic vistas more complex
visual effects
displayed with 10 times the processing
power per pixel
of halo 5. this will be running at a
flawless 60 frames per second and will
allow us to bring the halo ring to life
in ways that have never been possible
before we look forward to sharing even
more about halo infinite in the coming
months
including the first look at multiplayer
and now
please enjoy a glimpse of what others in
the xbox game studios family have been
working on
[Music]
world premiere